Well, attention
because a recent survey
shows what European countries think
about Argentine sovereignty
over the Falkland Islands.
That is,
who believe that the Falklands should be Argentinean.
Recall that recently
the European Union
considered the Falkland Islands as a territory
to the surprise of many,
8 countries were surveyed and of course England.
57% believe that the islands belong to them,
16% believe they are from Argentina
and the rest remain neutral.
In Denmark,
for example,
31% believe they are from England
and 23 percent believe they belong to the world champion.
In Switzerland,
28 percent thinks they are from England and 23 percent think they
are from England and 23 percent think they are from England.
from Argentina.
A lot of lukewarm people around here.
And this gets nice because in France
Argentina has more support.
23 percent believe the Falklands are English
compared to 27% who believe they should be Argentinean.
In Germany, eh,
24 percent is with England,
but 30% with us.
Good Italy,
Italy never fails.
It is the second European country that supports us the most.
with 30 and 2% compared to 21% who support England.
I think there is a lot of Maradona influence here.
Tremendous bonus track,
United States,
where 30 and 5% support England
and 21% to us.
And the European country that showed the most support for Argentina
is Spain,
where a tiny 14% is with England,
while with 52% of Spanish respondents
believe that the Falklands are Argentinean.
Fact,
the pollster is you go,
an international firm based in Great Britain.
Well, guys